wir haben eine nachricht bekommen von
unserem mitglied nahm aus vietnam er
schreibt ich höre sehr oft das wort so
und ich denke dass das wort viele
bedeutungen hat wenn ich eure
transkriptionen angucke könnt ihr das
mal erklären genau das machen wir heute
denn mir ist das persönlich auch noch
nie aufgefallen eigentlich dass dieses
kleine wort so sehr viele verschiedene
mögliche bedeutungen und übersetzungen
hat und noch etwas ist schwierig an dem
wort denn es wird oft verwechselt mit
dem englischen wort so beide wörter
werden gleich geschrieben und sie können
auch in einem fall das gleiche bedeuten
aber manchmal eben nicht und deswegen
stellen wir euch heute mal die
verschiedenen bedeutungen des wortes so
vor los geht's fangen wir an mit der
ersten bedeutung von so und die es
vielleicht auch die einfachste denn in
dieser bedeutung ist so eine steigerung
oder eine intensivierung man sagt zum
beispiel das ist so gut und das ist auch
schon der fall in dem so auf deutsch und
so im englischen ungefähr das gleiche
bedeuten man kann sagen bis es so gut
das ist so gut
[Musik]
was hast du dir gekocht ja ich habe den
ganzen morgen daran gearbeitet die ist
so gut
in der zweiten bedeutung ist so so etwas
wie ein pronomen ich kann sagen das ist
so ein schönes mikrofon und dem
englischen würde man das wahrscheinlich
mit touch übersetzen das ist das
mikrofon
und sag mal würdest du mir das rezept
man ja gerne das ist ganz minimalistisch
wasser ein paar tomaten und dann zwei
drei stunden ziehen lassen es ist so ne
gute idee
das ist richtig genial und
die dritte bedeutung von so ist schon
wieder ein bisschen anders hier würde
man so mit like that übersetzen ich kann
zum beispiel sagen so sollte ich das
mikrofon nicht halten ich weiß nicht ob
der ton jetzt noch gut war chris und dem
englischen will ich sagen
der microphone livewette und dieses like
that ist im deutschen dann so so sollte
ich das nicht machen
wir haben es so geht das nicht
danke
ja so nicht kommen
es wird so gemacht
die vierte variante von so ist
tatsächlich sehr ähnlich zu der dritten
aber es ist eine andere dort
variationen und zwar ist es das wort
genauso genauso ist ein eigenes wort und
man übersetzt es ungefähr mit exactly
like that man kann zum beispiel sagen
genau so sollte kari das mikrofon halten
[Musik]
genau sogar
die fünfte variante von so benutzt man
in vergleichen ich kann sagen ich bin
nicht so gut im gitarre spielen wie
janisch im englischen würde man das
vielleicht übersetzen mit es ein nord es
geht es ja nie
[Musik]
verdammt ich bin nicht so gut wie du
die nächste bedeutung von so ist
vielleicht die schwierigste denn man
kann sie nicht wirklich übersetzen aber
man kann diese idee ziemlich schnell
erklären im deutschen benutzt man ein so
immer dann wenn man zeigen möchte dass
jetzt etwas neues beginnt dass sich
etwas ändert ich kann zum beispiel sagen
so das war's jetzt tschüss und
dann gab es die verhandlungen und die
verhandlungen
behandlung
[Musik]
ich muss jetzt los
das was ihr gerade gesehen habt ist
vielleicht so etwas wie ein typisch
deutscher ausdruck oder eine typische
situation in deutschland man sitzt ganz
gemütlich zusammen denkt an etwas
schönes und plötzlich sagt der deutsche
so und kündigt damit das ende des
gemeinsamen abends an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt ist schluss
so das ist doch jetzt mal eine gute
gelegenheit um euch den sponsor unser
heutigen episode vorzustellen und das
ist nord wpm vielleicht habt ihr schon
mal von nord- wie pm gehört das ist
nämlich ein service mit dem ihr eure ip
adresse im internet maskieren könnt und
das ist unter anderem dann hilfreich
wenn ihr zum beispiel in einem
öffentlichen wlan sicher surfen möchte
oder wenn ihr zum beispiel die ip
adresse eines anderen landes annehmen
möchte ich benutze es zum beispiel wenn
ich eine serie in england oder den usa
gucken möchte die in deutschland nicht
verfügbar ist und ihr könnt das benutzen
wenn ihr vielleicht mal in deutschland
einen film oder eine serie gucken möchte
zum beispiel bei netflix oder in der ard
mediathek und dort etwas sehen möchte
was vielleicht in eurem land nicht
verfügbar ist wenn ihr das mal
ausprobieren wollt dann geht auf nord-
wie pr.com / german oder benutzt den
kupon cortesi german denn dann weiß nord
vpn dass ihr von uns kommt und dann
erhaltet ihr einen gratismonat und einen
riesen rabatt auf das 2 jahres paket die
letzte variante die wir euch vorstellen
ist das doppel so man sagt so so wenn
man zeigen möchte dass man etwas
verstanden hat aber vielleicht nicht
ganz glaubt was derjenige gerade gesagt
hat
[Musik]
llanos
hier sieht schon wieder aus wie kraut
und rüben
erst nicht klar ich werde heute abend
doch alles hier aufräumen heute brücke
an sieht es hier super aus
soso
[Musik]
als letztes schauen wir uns noch ein
beliebtes missverständnis an denn im
englischen gibt es eine variante von so
die es im deutschen nicht gibt und zwar
stellt euch vor dass ihr mit euren
freunden durch die stadt geht ihr sucht
ein restaurant aber alle restaurants
sind schon voll und dann sagt ihr zu
euren freunden in englisch so what you
think what we do you know in diesem fall
würde man im deutschen nicht so benutzen
sondern also das deutsche also ist also
in manchen fällen die form des
englischen soul und das höre ich
tatsächlich sehr oft dass das englische
muttersprachler falsch benutzen man
würde nie sagen so was denkst du man
würde sagen also was denkst du ist
[Musik]
regnet in strömen
also denkst du wir können zu hause
bleiben ich glaub ja
okay
also gehe ich die tage spielen ja in
diesen szenen habt ihr zwei mal das wort
also gehört und zweimal wurde es mit so
übersetzt also beschreibt also immer
eine konsequenz es regnet also bleiben
wir hier wir bleiben hier also
kenianisch gitarre spielen vielleicht
kann man sich das gut merken dadurch
dass ihr im englischen das wort mit wer
vor übersetzen könnte oder austauschen
könnte also immer wenn ihr somit wer vor
austauschen könnt könnt ihr also
benutzen und am ende noch mal als
zusammenfassung für alle leute die
manchmal das englisch und das deutsche
verwechseln es gibt nur einen einzigen
fall in dem so und so identisch sind und
das ist diese intensivierung die wir am
anfang des videos gezeigt haben bis es
so gut das ist so gut in diesem fall
benutzt man in beiden sprachen so und so
so das war's für heute wenn ihr jetzt
noch mal die verschiedenen varianten von
so üben möchtet dann könnt ihr das mit
unseren interaktiven übungen tun als
mitglied von the german unterstützt die
unsere arbeit für nur 5 euro im monat
und erhaltet gleichzeitig zu allen
videos von uns ein interaktives
übungsplatz mit dem ihr die themen der
aktuellen episode noch einmal intensiver
üben könnte und wenn ihr mal eine
grammatik frage habt die wir vielleicht
in einem video beantworten können dann
schreibt uns gerne einen kommentar
schuss und bis bald